hello everybody hope that you are good
welcome to today's Bitcoin update in
yesterday's video we were talking about
the possibility of a short squeeze
that's a pump to the upside to retrace
this liquidity pool over here and we set
a Target at 26 700. you can see that
yesterday's New York session they push
price up all right and they hit 26 631.
that's close isn't it I think that's
only like 70 dollars away right so I
think that that Target is then hit I'm
gonna remove the liquidity pool over
there because I think that that's pretty
much retraced
okay and now if I look at the chart we
were talking about this week okay but if
you notice this week the only thing that
is doing is
fill in our previous one that's why I
told you in yesterday's video that I'm
not focused and obsessed with this week
okay because the all intention in
creating this week was to fill a
previous week right
um now if I look at the chart I can see
another liquidity pool to the upside in
this Zone over here
all right so that's going to be an
interesting show in the chart let me
Mark it
so it's clear
now if you notice you know price is
going up
so that's good but it's going up very
slowly all right uh something is telling
me that today we could see a bigger move
maybe like a you know
seven hundred dollars move or something
like that and that could take us to this
liquidity pool over here
you can only think like the market maker
once you understand how the retail
Trader thinks okay that's what I like
Twitter because I can see what other
Traders are doing right and I could tell
me what the retail traded is is looking
at
so what I'm saying lately is you know
this kind of
um trend line here all right I don't
even know how to draw it uh something
like that all right so you have this
trend line here
okay and what the original Trader is
doing is you know they're gonna they see
like price bouncier bounce here again
here again here so you know if price
comes here what are they expecting a
bounce if price comes here what are they
expecting a bounce so they're gonna have
Longs with high Leverage
on this training all right and I tell
you what I'm saying lately with this
type of train lines okay I explained it
another video but well I usually sit
with this trend line is
let me Mark it for you we see you now
all of these moves that you know spoons
and Ray traces all good all right and
then in one of these moments before it
breaks down because just not below this
stream and there is a lot of liquidity
there is a lot of stop losses all right
the little Trader that opened the
position here
or here is placing the rest stop losses
is adjusting the stop losses below the
straight line all right honestly you
have to think that you know everything
that pie the price puts up there are new
orders
stacked in this trend line okay so uh
usually I'll tell you what I see before
they break down
I'm usually seeing a very aggressive
push-up
and then a big dump
that's what I'm usually seeing with this
type of trend lines okay
um Can this play out today
I mean I don't think that that is enough
time
probably today to to push up
aggressively and then again this could
take some days to play out all right but
why not maybe today we can see the first
part of this move maybe we're gonna
start to see a very aggressive push-up
you know
um that's what I'm keeping an eye on
also if you notice let's go to the Daily
time frame well actually what do we hear
let's change the time frame to the Daily
time frame all right and see what the 50
amaz okay so the 50ma is actually
higher than I thought okay I thought it
was going to be more around this one
here all right so I mean still even if
they fill this liquidity pool
the 50 I mean the daily time frame is
still a bit higher right so it's just
telling you that this one here
should act as resistance this trend line
I will tell you is the reason why I'm
not expecting
add them from here today because I'm
thinking that it's more likely that we
see one more push-up quite aggressive I
need to see an aggressive push-up
okay once we have the aggressive push up
then
I'll be favorite idea
of going lower all right so at the
moment I can't favor lower prices so
that's at least what I'm doing I'm
favoring still the pricing continue
going higher
okay because yes to be honest this move
here
it's quite a nice move okay you know
it's going up retracing going up
retracing going over traces is it's an
organic move up right so
um I like the move to be honest but I
still think that there is an aggressive
push-up left but that's what I'm
thinking possibly
to this liquidity pool over here that's
around 27 200 ish okay
where can you open positions well it
depends on how you trade both for
example let me remove this uh do you
know that you have here
quite a strong resistance right in this
Zone here so why not a price push up
okay breaks above it and closes the the
candle body above this trailer and then
it is a support
you can open along here okay so that's
one of them of course you have to be
careful because this one here
it's also resistance so for example what
you can do is
longing in this retrace maybe you can
even close the position here okay and
then if price goes higher and rate this
again here you can open another long
here okay this depends how you play I'm
just giving you some ideas okay this is
quite a safe way to play this Zone over
here
but the question is why is Bitcoin
pumping you know since Thursday okay if
we go to the dollar Index okay we can
see that the volar index is currently
retracing you can see that the top was
on Thursday and since then it's free
tracing quite a lot so I think that's
why Bitcoin is going up now right the
question is Canon is still retrace
um I think yes because if you notice
there is a liquidity pool in this Zone
over here for example
all right and if we go to the four hour
time frame
uh you can even see here even more clear
all right it's even bigger here so why
not I think that the dollar Index has a
chance
to come to this Zone still all right
maybe even today and that would give
Bitcoin the opportunity to continue
pushing higher
um to be honest if you go to the Daily
time frame
you can see that you know it's been
moving higher for two weeks okay and you
can see that it's forming this double
view pattern okay we were talking about
this potential
a scenario for quite some time I will
then tell you like more than a month ago
okay after all you guys you know the
dollar is looking good because you have
here
hello then sweep of the lows that's a
double re button with supervillous
that's very bullish okay so as long as
we didn't close a candle below this one
here okay
then
we were only going to see price going up
and that's what it's doing all right now
the volume is gonna face some really
strong resistance
for example in this Zone over here okay
that's going to be an important
resistance and that's to be honest quite
close
um I think that it's very likely that it
continues retracing maybe uh to the
liquidity pool that we mentioned okay
that would take us
all the way to
the market for you
low 103 maybe 103.2 103.1 ish
that's what I think I think that it's
likely that this could even happen today
or next week okay and that would give
Bitcoin the possibility to continue
going higher
I also want to remind you that we are
collaborating with bit yet so the
community can have some benefits when
trading for example a 15 discount on
trading fees which is quite High because
we usually see ten percent discount with
other exchanges but they are giving us
15 percent Which is higher also when you
sign up you get five dollar bonus
deposits between two hundred dollars and
a thousand dollars to get a ten percent
payback which means that for example if
you deposit let's say 500 you get fifty
dollars for free there are also some
rewards for higher deposits in case you
want to deposit more
um of course there is a giveaway of 10
places for free for my trading course in
July
um The Centers of winning are quite High
because 10 places are Kuala so do you
need to create an account and it doesn't
require kyc so it's quite easy and quite
fast and you only need to deposit at
least a hundred dollars and then you are
participating and we're gonna say the
winners in four days
and the exchange is proactive and they
are rewarding Traders they have this
event going on at the moment is
finishing in two days and it's called
candy bomb you can see the retails here
and it's basically an airdrop once you
complete some tasks for example trading
volume in a sport or in Futures so
that's pretty much everything guys thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you soon